survive after a shooting at a southern
california church let's take this press
conference live from the orange county
sheriff's department
stephen galloway
assistant special agent in charge atf
los angeles
lisa bartlett orange county board of
supervisors fifth district
and carol moore the goodwood mayor
we will take questions at the conclusion
of this press conference
good afternoon
first and foremost i want to send our
thoughts and prayers to all those that
are impacted by this incident this is a
very tragic
incident for the victims their families
and this entire community
i want to start by asking for your
patience also as you know this is an
active investigation that's been going
on for less than four hours
our investigators are still diligently
processing the scene so we're here to
provide as much information as we can at
the time but again just uh i ask for
your patience and please understand that
we're working as quickly as we can to
have more details in the information
that you're looking for
at about 1 26 p.m this afternoon a male
subject opened fire here at the geneva
presbyterian church in the city of
laguna woods
one person is confirmed deceased at the
scene
four others are critical and one other
victim sustained minor injuries
the injured victims were taken to local
hospitals we currently do not have a
status of the injured four that are in
critical condition
when deputies arrived on scene they
provide immediate medical aid to the
victims here at the church
shortly after our partners from the
orange county fire authority arrived on
scene and began providing advanced
medical life-saving measures
we're very grateful to the orange county
fire authority for their quick response
and their ability to provide critical
life-saving treatment
the incident happened at lunch
at a lunch bump uh banquet following the
morning service and again to remind you
this is all very preliminary information
we believe a group of churchgoers detain
him and hog tight his legs with an
extension cord and confiscated at least
two weapons from him he was detained
when the deputies arrived
that group of churchgoers displayed what
we believe is exceptional heroism
heroism and bravery in interviewing or
intervening to stop the suspect
they undoubtedly prevented additional
injuries and fatalities
the suspect was not injured during the
incident he's taken into custody
he's believed to be an asian male adult
in his 60s
we don't believe he lives in this area
investigators are working to determine
his city of residence and whether he has
any connection to this church or to the
congregation
[Music]
at this time we do not know what the
suspect's motive may be or whether he
had an intended target or whether this
is even an age-related incident
following the incident the sheriff's
department hazardous device section
utilized bomb canines and swept the
church grounds to ensure there were no
secondary devices
members from the trauma intervention
program also are on scene to provide
crisis counseling to the congregants
multiple ocfa resources responded as
part of the potential mci a mass
casualty incident as part of the active
shooter response
resources included multiple firefighter
paramedic units are a specialized mass
casualty unit private ground ambulances
and a helicopter air ambulance
the nci was declared and our firefighter
paramedics quickly
triaged treated and transported five
patients the undersheriff said four
critical and one minor status
and one victim was pronounced deceased
at the sea
in addition ocfa chaplains responded to
the church the hospitals we also have
started our critical incident distress
debriefing
for our ocfa first responders
our hearts are with the victims
their families and our community thank
you
thank you
again that was the sheriff's department
there in california they're saying that
at 1 30 this afternoon a man opened fire
at geneva presbyterian church in laguna
woods four people are in critical
condition one has died another has minor
injuries now they say this all happened
at a lunch banquet following a morning
service at that church they believe a
group of churchgoers actually detained
that suspect tied him up and took his
weapons that suspect they say was not
hurt he is a man in his 60s according to
sheriff's deputies they are working to
determine where he is from they don't
believe he lives in the laguna woods
area no word on a motive here now again
this is the second mass shooting here in
the united states this weekend we will
of course continue to follow this as
this story develop